[Music]
[Applause]
episode
okay why haven't i got my knife up oh
balls yeah i have like hardly any
ammunition do i
okay so i've got this new key which i
know is to down here
and that's probably gonna be the next
boss actually it goes back around
doesn't it
back onto the bottom of the map right
let's use this
because there's also a door on the other
side of the map
but perhaps that door is too a boss
this one isn't [ __ ] jesus christ
[ __ ] hell
i mean i wasn't expecting this
jesus christ
i'm already yelling at him oh no
ethan you've got no bullets why you do
this to yourself
oh great
nope nope
oh it's [ __ ] hunting me
in the leg
oh god
[Applause]
did i even get it
can i can this thing be killed
oh no oh no
okay this one got no ammunition
um
oh my god where is the freaking grenade
launcher
can i make anything
no no no no no i could make it mine
if i put this one down here maybe and
then i'm like
hello hello
i'm ethan i'm making lots of noise
please come here
i can hear him where the [ __ ] is he
come on you stupid dog come to me
where the [ __ ] is it
oh there's a gun i can hear it
can you guys hear it
oh there it is hey baby
hey baby okay let's go
okay run run even run run run even
i need to find some army
there it is
[ __ ] jesus christ is fast it's fast
hello ah i was hoping we could pluck out
its eyeballs
wow that's lovely not even being
sarcastic it is lovely
um let's go sell it and see if we can
get anything with that
hey look what i did i just killed a
beasty beast beast beast
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the time
i've gotten some new stock
i don't think i have enough to make any
more oh yeah i want to i want to get the
um
movement speed one don't i so i need to
get the finest
fish and some more fish but i did sell a
fish so i have a feeling like i can't do
this anymore
and my eyes watering for some reason
what's happening to me
i'm crying i'm crying is it because i
killed the wolf okay
let's sell this i still need to find
something to go
in the hole
dissatisfied i believe this is a fair
price
yeah it'll do i guess what's this
flashbangs hmm
i want to just buy a shotgun ammo i
should probably shouldn't do that
thank you for your time i won't do that
i'll just buy five um
good day then
i'm glad you like that video edits on
i hope you don't mind me calling you
some song um
yeah um jacob came up with that
he watched it and he was i'm really
sorry i'm gonna have to troll you really
hard
and i was like it's fair
i completely understand
i unlocked it and now what am i gonna
find
launcher [ __ ] yeah
i knew i'd find it eventually
that would have helped me with that
stupid werewolf
oh yeah let me know if i am too loud if
the game's too loud if i'm
blowing out your speakers or something
because i have a tendency to do that
so please let me know
so is there anything down here that i
should actually be looking out for
or there should be [ __ ] in there
well uh let's check the map
well there's chickens
and there's uh something here a
mechanical door so let's go
over there then
[Music]
should we um unlock that door
can we unlock this door from here from
this side
i don't know which way am i going
turn around this way
and this way no other way
so is it in here then gosh can't see a
bloody thing
chickens
i can hear them i think they're outside
oh damn it i need to be out there
here okay i'll find a way to them
i'm over this place just kept running
around and around and around
uh hmm so how do i get around the back
aha yah
that's nice uh oh
what do i need i need some kind of
other item
hmm
photo of a bird maybe no that's not
gonna work
okay so we don't have this item you know
what i can't i can't see i'm gonna have
to
turn up the uh brightness i'm sorry
one second
ta-da right
chickens how do i get to you
nothing
i mean i've got to find it some find
something somewhere
i thought i cleared this place out of
like creepy [ __ ]
don't panic stop panicking
oh my god
[Applause]
no don't say that anymore it's not good
you're gonna stop saying that
they actually got your shots which is
what did i just get so i just got the
the
did let's just get what i needed
hell yeah okay
was there anywhere else around here
though that i couldn't go before
that might give me some nice yummy ammo
on the lookout for yummy ammo yummy ammo
yummy ammo yummy yummy
well that's freaking weird
did we see this before
looks breakable
it worked the knife works guys
well i guess we're going to go through
the sludgy sludge sludge
but not quite yet
but what about the other door no i'm
gonna have to check out the other door
first because i'm just gonna be
wondering things oh one way
i really hope i can get this stamina
boost it would be very nice
viennese
oh what i didn't it's just a bloody well
wheel
okay fine let's go to
the locked door
is that the log door though
no i can't unlock it from this i thought
i might be able to unlock it from this
side
it will be useful but i guess not
okay so we know to go down there
is to the mermaid boss but what is
up here is what i'm wondering
because there is another door
that we couldn't open because we needed
this new key which we now have
oh apparently it's different to the key
that we've got it looks the same
oh we need another set of wings okay got
you
got you game got you right
okay mermaid boss we go oh
is this a fresh thing of flowers
fresh flowers there's probably been that
the whole entire game and i've only just
noticed
we were back i'm crafting fried chicken
in the middle of battle
jeez sounds hectic
okay so there's nothing else here for me
to get which is a shame i need more
ammunition game
come on count a girl some slack
i mean i guess i didn't check upstairs
in here but
i doubt there's anything really
oh that's a pretty little windmill up
this way
that's pretty
mermaid piss
[Music]
oh i can
there's piggies for me
they'll probably kill me first though
but i
i don't want to waste uh you know i'm
gonna have
in the book
oh [ __ ] it got me
it got me
piggy
ah okay okay okay okay i see
i see i'm gonna pick up that cog thing
from
in here then what does it say laboratory
oh gosh
i didn't know mermaids lived in
laboratories
hello ah
i see i have to find it all
i will find this ball
do i have any ammo for this one aha
okay
a photo of a rare animal oh where is
that
i actually don't know what that is it
looks like anywhere in this whole map
i don't know it'll be back in the main
bit though i'm guessing
a rare piggy pig pig
reservoir elevator
oh save okay
if
nothing no i'm okay
this is the first time it's just that
troll that troll got me i was doing so
good with ammunition and then that troll
just nearly bled me dry
literally as well
which way am i looking i'm getting dizzy
oh my gosh there's so much it's called a
load
i'm guessing that's going to be locked
it looked like it had the lock of the
last key as well
so where
are we what is this why are we here
actually i know why we're here but where
are we
i don't know anything about this
hence why i keep calling it the mermaid
because of the little logo
no can i just squeeze through that yes
there she is my baby pot
uh she's just watching
white noise
[Music]
oh my god
i'll just be taking this wait wait wait
what are you doing with mother's special
child she's not herself
what do you mean mother's special child
mother
wants her baby back don't screw with me
wait wait wait please please
if you take it let the others laugh at
me
but
[Music]
you're stupid you talk too much
it's all over i plugged away in
what are you this is
my territory
damn freak
i'm going
[Music]
how do i get out of here
like this ethan you're out
something's wrong
come out of the underground bit sure but
leave the boat key in the shack of the
mine
in the shack in the mine hans is dead no
more fishing for a while i mean
we all know his death was no accident he
was eaten by a giant
fish okay stay out of water stay out of
the water
got it got it i mean i would anyway
because it's a horror game and
you never want to go in the water in a
horror game so
a little boot on a chair
okay
oh no all right so it's a shack always
say
it's a shack in the mind so let's go
back in the mine
i don't remember seeing the shack
maybe this would be a good time for me
to actually swap out
my grenade launcher and give this a
little
give it a whirl
i'm gonna save it for now bye
did i not just shorthand it
apologies shorthand this one
yes
oh hello
hello
some thoughts could break it
take that
oh i see you there sneaky sneaky barrel
aha boy thank you
it would be nice to get more ammo but
i'll take whatever i can
get
no
um
oh you
just yell at them and they go away
aha look at this a shack
how very convenient gun powder
very nice very nice
maybe soon i'll be able to make some
ammo
oh yeah
it's very nice very nice not breakable
barrel only yellow barrel is breakable
arrow
i see breakfall barrel well
here
how did you not [ __ ] die from that
what are you
oh yeah buzzy
ah jesus
uh where are you they're gonna find the
way in
got you in your bowls
how did you not know that you could just
walk around the back and the doors open
[Applause]
i'm not gonna complain
where are they
oh
gummy gigs snakes
i don't know how they don't understand
that they can come just behind me
but you know what i don't care because
they stupid
getting you in your bag
that was so funny at first it was so
like
tense because i was like oh crap they're
gonna come behind me
but they never did i thought you know
i am the intelligent one here so i have
the upper hand
i shouldn't be so cocky really because
something's gonna happen
and i'm gonna regret being so cocky i
know it
okay do we have everything we need here
no
there are things to pick up
but it's quite a large area so the
oh how do i go can i go in this water
because i i don't want to miss a thing i
don't want
this thing because i need every every
little bit of help that i can possibly
get oh i got it
got it all sweet
metal scrap that's what i picked up
earlier right
um oh not enough to make any bullets
apart from an explosive round oh you
have to give up a half to make an
explosive round
damn
you're wearing the smarty pants this
tiny ass
i am i am i put them on especially
sweet
i'm glad i had this though because that
that gun made it so much
easier
okay off we go time to go back
ah no i didn't get the dish of the fish
and that's that's the one i need but i
have
sold a fish and people were like no she
salt fish she'll never get it back now
and i'm like oh no
so i'm hoping that just because i sold
one fish it's not going to change
everything but it might do
oh see you
i see you
i'll save it
you're playing dead for a second there
got your foot
oh jesus
he's like i'm dead and then he's like
just go up
oh okay i just saw
something over here how do we get to it
okay fine is there anything for me to
pick up around here
let's go into the spooky cave
oh that's so cool i love it
oh i thought i could go down this way to
get the treasure
i love sea monsters
what the hell research post or something
what the [ __ ] are they doing here
stay the [ __ ] down ethan
i gotta say i'm surprised you made it
this far
it'd be a shame if something happened to
you now sir chris
why not you killed mia now do me and
finish the job
hey cat i'm getting some serious motion
readings out here
we should move on yes big giant fish
what kind of readings what's moving
unknown but my guess is we've been here
too long and miranda knows it hey
hey did you say miranda how are you
involved leave it alone ethan you are
out of your depth
what about the sample analysis it's
definitely related to the mold
i think it's time
oh
[ __ ] stay back
what
you're doing i don't have time for this
miranda sent you to slow me down
[Music]
what are you talking about
the [ __ ] is wrong
is this the sea creature
[Music]
oh jesus
not even gonna attempt to shoot at this
thing because i know i'm just gonna be
wasting ballets
so the exits underwater
well it looks like we're gonna have to
be finding a submarine then
can we climb up those ladders
so chris do we reckon he survived
he definitely survived didn't he yeah
what am i supposed to do
i don't know i guess we go to moroes
clinic and put this hat on
what's up here
he said the exit's underwater
house
okay
something's sleeping
ethan oh it's you
duke as you wish
that was great mr winters ah
[Music]
that's so funny
ah
i'm skilled at all sorts of have a
wonderful adventure
yeah sorry you can go back to sleep now
i'm sorry i interrupted you please
please go back to sleep
i'll save
i feel much more safe now knowing that
it was just
duke and i was scared of
the duke
i need to explore down a little bit
because i came up here because i thought
damn was where i was supposed to be but
obviously elsewhere i'm supposed to go
so
before i go up
do i need to press something here as
well
oh lower lower there okay so it's some
sort of puzzle
here orange blue
blue blue black
it's not gonna do anything now drain the
water
[ __ ] there's no power
i guess didn't i look for little blocks
ethan's gonna play builder blocks
oh i can't go down there fair enough
what's this
uh reservoir gatehouse operations
instructions
in an instance of heavy rain there may
be damage to the local aquatic life
it's advised that you drain all excess
water using the following steps
move the windmills with a crank to start
the electricity to the gatehouse
oh okay so we go up to the windmill now
pull the lever in the gatehouse
to open this loose
can you make anything
and subscribe
i hate coughing but is that just choke
this far away
oh hello
seriously
nothing to pick up in here oh science
is that chickens chickens
do they miss the chickens
i'm sure i'll come back
oh no be careful ethan
pick up this fish
fish food
my impatience got the better of me
okay i gotta wait
oh don't get eaten by okay thanks
guys for some reason i thought he wanted
to
oh god
oh
wow impressive
oh my god now
nope nope nope
what am i supposed to do
okay so i mean i can definitely go this
way
and he was saying up and down so like
that definitely is a thing
oh right okay
ah go back nobody
okay
this one jump down
go go
here
damn
how am i gonna oh no i don't have to
walk across those beans
stinks
oh my goodness
oh okay good
wow
okay
what did that do
oh that one oh that must
stay up for longer okay but wait oh
there's someone please
go i don't know where to go
oh no okay so that's that one orange
white
orange
jesus christ i shall eat something i do
something wrong
oh no
no no no no i don't want to quit
oh thank god i thought i was going to
accidentally rage quit then
patience don't go yet
okay go now
i'm the best
positive affirmation
[Music]
issues
oh
okay he's over there
ew where did
that come from
okay
i don't know i i keep asking you guys
questions but i don't even know if i
want you to answer me
i'm just wondering out loud
[Music]
is that a glint or something
yeah it's it
oh this will be fun
oh
[Music]
i love how it's got a little arrow
look up here dummy
oh [ __ ] hell what the hell how'd he
jump so high
jesus christ
you can't climb it like this
why is i don't understand
now i get it
okay big boy can you get up here
it's going to take oh
don't worry ethan you've already
survived two um eating
i'm sure
okay
i promise you this is not what i do in
real life
i need fish though but i guess
i never knew
the last chicken
this crank is old and busted up it feels
like it's going to
snap at any second i hope it doesn't
break the only other
we have is over one more two oh i should
have read this before
but oh well i've read it now
hello wish to make a purchase
right please come again
aha okay so
bye oh it's already got it there for me
so this one
uh this is white that's nope
and maybe medium that's blue that's blue
oh that's gotta be black oh yeah yeah no
this is right
uh and then this is blue
gut
is not gonna be happy about this
watch all the water go down
thank you thank you for the praise
only two deaths i mean
what more do you expect really oh my
gosh
can i kill it now yeah boy i can kill it
now can i
say
[ __ ]
i probably just wasted that
make some more
i need scrap
ugh
what's this
oh no i do
not theme
october the first a sunny day mother
miranda
bought me five peoples from the village
just like i asked they did i made them
sleep with some liquid
and then i put kadeau in their tummies i
am looking forward to the kadeau to grow
in their tummies
october 2 a cloudy day
four of the people from the village are
dead this morning
one is almost a liken i sent it to my
lab on the mountain
i failed again mother wants strong
vessels but i cannot get any
i will need more people from the village
okay so they're experimenting on people
from the village to make them
likened but the lichen wasn't even
strong enough right
why what is mother mirando i sort of
really understand
her motive she wants a
child right he said something about
she will have her child
there's definitely a theme of fertility
and and children in this game
what with the doll and lady dimitrisk
who can have daughters
yes let's make some of these
perfect
i guess you gotta do this
oh my god don't stick on me don't you
dummy
no down okay
why am i doing weird things right
let's i thought i just picked the mine i
don't think i picked it up
you get on my way
okay
[Music]
let's get inside somewhere okay i [ __ ]
that up
well i know next time now
okay uh
oh my god
oh
oh
and there's a red bell
here ethan can you please be faster i
really hate
composure um
yes because we're out of ammo for that
one
we're doing all right on that kind of
you can probably get another picture
[Music]
my vows
hello
oh
[ __ ] jesus
oh my god
uh
no no no no no i am not here i don't
know who i'm talking to but i'm not
[Applause]
she's not here i'm not here
where are you
come on
[Music]
in so much
okay um
wait do i have lines on me oh i do i do
yay okay this is good this we can use
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
ah and death as he was in life
disgusting disgusting
and we didn't get things on our minds
[Music]
sweaty finger session over thank
goodness for that
ah that's nice okay let's oh
let's uh look around for some ammunition
and stuff and then
i think we're gonna call it a day i'm
very proud of us
look at let's go killing a boss in one
day
one stream
uh
i actually can't run anymore just
clicking in the thumb stick is hurting
so everything did they already pick up
everything i think i did
i'm quite surprised this is running
around like a bloody lunatic
i guess i did
okay
the exits up ahead
uh you guys are asking did i pick up the
thingy majigger
yeah yeah yeah it he got it
automatically once it died
it's crystal meru loads of little
eyeballs
no i don't have any help no
oh well hopefully i'll
find them soon oh there
you can make one now don't waste this
one please
oh this was this little room where it
was just
staring at the tv like this eating
cheese with
i thought that fork was flat floating
but then now i think it's in the cheese
mother miranda gave me a rose jar no one
likes me
which is why i thought they wouldn't
they would leave me out again
but heisenberg said that that was why we
each get a rose
the ceremony cannot happen without us
all there
mother didn't seem to care though mother
said rose is a vessel
with a vessel mother can get her real
child back
here we go even though she has been dead
for a very long time
but if mother does then what will happen
to me
i'm not her real child would she abandon
me
no i don't want that no no no no
no no it sounds like she was gonna go
crazy in the end anyway and
ruin mother miranda's plans
here it is can i
take it
tada you're better off than i thought
who's that oh come on we just met a
while back nothing really matters
you're the last [ __ ] in my way aren't
you
you've got fights i'll give you that
ethan
but what's the plan when you have all
four flasks
what are you trying to get at i could
lend you a hand
not trying to get out my good side i
don't get cocky
i'd kill you if you weren't worth the
trouble
there's a stronghold not too far outside
the village
go there and get my flask do that
and you pass first head back to the
graveyard
self-centered prick
okay
is that alive
is this what they give to the the
villagers
okay i'm not gonna lie i wasn't really
listening to what he said
through here because i was reading chat
but i'm sure i'll figure out where i'm
going
and we're out of here
see ya
hey jade hope you have a good night's
sleep
hey useless mug what an interesting name
it's safe here but i'm just gonna
oh i do have rose don't i okay thank god
yeah because
he never took it back from us
so let me just go back
and put her in there
no i don't have the ball for the puzzle
yet
maybe it's up here though because this
is
oh yes
[Applause]
oh
there's the bowl right we'll use it in a
[Applause]
second
[Applause]
oh my god [ __ ] hell what the hell oh
my god
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh
it's not really um very subtle
is he ethan not when i'm playing him
anyway
there's a spooky monster around here
somewhere i can hear you
okay
disappear
should we just do it
monsters
can you please come
may you please come on
hey
thank you
mother miranda gave me a mountain
now i can do lots and lots of caddo
experiments this is my secret special
laboratory
i did three caddo experiments today but
they all went pop
and made a mess i put in the cuddle and
then i tried putting some
putting wolf blood from a needle into
the spline spline
into the spine spine the person wiggled
a lot
and then killed my assistant i could not
hold it down so i put it in a cage and
now i have to feed it
oh no am i gonna have to kill this one
no
um i'm gonna make some room for those
ah okay it's like
oh it's a lot of slots um
like this uh one two
one two three four one two three yeah
wait wait
yeah that's fine can i
can we keep this over here
please
huh i thought i did it
they go
i got a special really really good
looking gun
where the [ __ ] is down there
it's gotta be behind the house
should we try this magnum
oh [ __ ] not you again whoa
this gun is a messy
that's so good where did you come from
though where were you locked up in
that was confusing
don't say that
ugh
okay nothing behind the house
i think we're good again let's put the
ball in
is
mermaid it's a beautiful mermaid
so this evening
oh [ __ ]
this is so odd
come on come on come on little ball
you can do it yay
now we can go kill some chickens
because uh we have the little crank
thing don't we something
uh
oh my god i just i just had this
realization that it's thursday
and ah that's a nice feeling
right anyway a chicken does not escape
nothing in the fancy
fancy [ __ ] but there is a ladder
what is up here
i feel like one of the likens
there
nice thanks game
this way papa
it's a little bit weird uh oh the door's
open okay one sec let me just go
to here
uh we'll put her in first
arms
so we got head i think we got legs
arms and i guess the next one is torso
ah my apologies
he's got that weird thing please do take
a look at my new stock
this is lord moroes i suppose it's what
they call
the beauty of the grotesque
securing goods is more important than
anything
anything my friend good day then
where do i get fish in this game okay
that is where i'm gonna call it for the
evening
yeah my head's like sure like
no yeah i should call it here so thank
you so much for watching
um another great episode and
i'm very proud that we managed to kill a
boss in one stream
i mean yeah
next week next thursday 8 30 p.m
bst time so whatever that is your time
and yeah i'll see you then
you